you never seen the long Chardon football
you never seen Jody of joy Diaz is so
thick enough how big is he in that
[ __ ] so big they were worried you
know what am i favorite okay when I'll
do the wedding senior dude oh the very
first time okay man look at this look at
that right there look at that dude
you know with that picture in mind the
very first time he tried ecstasy I had
given it to him right and he went over
to this woman's house who he was dating
at the time dating is wrong word she had
a restraining order against them and he
go he was like give me one of those
ecstasy pills I'm going over see and I'm
not gonna say her name and so you went
over right now they had a weird
relationship and so they went in and
they were gonna mess around but she had
told her neighbor you see this dude call
the cops oh so they're about to get into
it and Joey just taking his ecstasy and
there's a knock on the door police
so she goes and opens the door and she's
like he's like the cops like we're here
this guy's in here and she's like no
he's like well we got to come in and
take a look and she told me I said so
did they find him and she said the
police officer said ma'am why is your
mattress breathing cuz he was under the
bed
and he the first time he took ecstasy he
said it started hit him in the backseat
of a cop car cuffed and he started to
just roll his brains oh yeah man it's
fantastic you know he's in The Sopranos
movie yes and that you know what's
interesting I think is you start off
there's a little role yeah he [ __ ]
nailed it so they keep getting do more
more and more is that movie coming out I
think it's got postponed right right
right it's good and I cuz I think David
Kelley's a little older - I'm not sure
he wants but also with Joey Diaz it's
like dude of course season sub-province
of course you put him in Soprano kiya he
listen guys I mean I could write a Joey
Diaz story plan Oh John Rizzo he okay
my the the first time I realized that
this dude is just a giant teddy bear I
used to run this place in Pioneer Square
in Seattle and when he first came to
Seattle I hired him to work the door and
on Tuesday nights I had a night there a
fetish night because I like weird [ __ ]
and I like to watch people do weird [ __ ]
and you know it's the first time I'd
ever seen some a dude lay under a glass
table and pay $100 to watch a girl [ __ ]
on the table I don't like that no I
don't like that either but I had to see
it once just to see what was going on
you know what I mean it's like no Carter
yeah thing about the girl - is willing
to do that
this dude was literally dick out jacking
off yeah the whole time
Wow yeah I don't know how you find out
that's your thing but it makes work how
many things do you go through before
you're like that's the one theater has
got that great bit about that or he goes
before the internet like how would you
find out somebody's in the same fetish
you're yeah I'm gonna go pee let's run a
pee on your face
whose butt is that [ __ ] mixed force
that's you know it's money I betcha
nurse warts and said that out loud
before
but so we there was one there was one
night the first night he worked there
well there were these two old queens
dressed like basically two women from
gone with the wind and they had parasols
and they were talking to each other and
it was hilarious and was super fun but
they just started to yell at each other
real loud guy Joey I know come on I know
you gotta get these guys out of here and
it was what they looked like they had a
good time I'm like no man you gotta
they're screaming at each other it's
it's you gotta get him out here and he
goes okay
and he goes hey and you know he's
straight like his vernacular he when he
doesn't think he's being offensive it's
just the way he talks
yeah hey come on you two queens you
gotta go in there like what yeah they
just want you out here I think you're
dressed nice but you gotta go and so he
grabs them by one elbow eats just to
walk him out well they have their
parasols and they're there just wow and
he's walking out getting hit he called
him umbrella stop hitting me with your
umbrellas but he's laughing the whole
way out he came back inside I go you
didn't get mad he goes that was the
funniest [ __ ] [ __ ] that's ever
happened to me yeah he goes they just
beat me up with her there's no they
kidnapped a guy and I was like laughing
yeah so goes hey he's not joking no he's
not oh yeah yeah he had that guy on his
podcast daddy brought him back right he
kidnap he kid down his mom over you know
what yeah and he told me he was I go you
kidnapped a guy he was yeah but he was a
drug dealer I'm like that's okay yeah
it's still kidnap he was like yeah but
it's okay maíam I know probably I was
why he went to jail right I believe so
yeah yeah yeah well in Seattle he went
to jail for a there is um for something
completely different he still can't go
to Seattle cuz I think he's got a
warrant out there you can't go to see
Ellen one other
anywhere outside of the United States
that's the one on e yeah I would I still
say if you tell me Joey Diaz calls an
apologize yeah there's nobody else in
the world who has that headline on top
of high school pain
I have his first headshot on here
somewhere but you know you know he
obviously he used to babysit my kids and
I found one of his a little beautiful
heiress dude come on man he looks like
you so welcome back kotter he looks like
Juan Epstein right [ __ ] there
um wait a second where where is Joey's
the best cuz we have the same eight we
all have the same agent Justin and just
ago
Hotel Justin goes we we sent him Brendan
job and then Justin and tell him and
then Joey economy goes you're not
[ __ ] going there you need help tell
me what to do and I call Justin like hey
man so I'm not I'm not going to New
Jersey I'm not playing that place and
I'm not flying there you think we just
talked to Joey I'm like yeah man he but
dude so we stole the safe once I think
I've told you this story before but we
stole a safe once and this epitomizes
him for me also after I was like hey man
so he's like me right now I said here's
what's he kind of look like a young
Andre the Giant in that picture yeah but
I said hey man here's the deal I said if
we get caught he goes man if we get
caught don't worry about it that's what
he mean he goes well I'm just gonna say
I took the safe
I said why this is what's his mentality
you know he didn't think he was gonna
live to 50 you know his daughter saved
his life yeah but he said to me he was
young man but if if we get caught I'll
go to jail he said you got a family who
you have people in this world who love
you I don't have anybody because mom
died yeah all of them right he was like
I who cares if I go to jail and that was
his mentality yeah he was like who cares
if I go to the most loving guy yeah the
best yeah he is he's also man one of the
few dudes who I'll pick up the phone for
I'm like mostly what you're calling I'm
like I know why is this dude attacked
like a while ago in studio takes me he
calls me ya know
I'm gonna text you he's just not kind of
thing he'll text me gross pictures and
we videos those pictures or those
pictures he send me yeah
but told me the other day worried about
Corona and not being on the tour I'm
like Joey I'm good man
yeah he's like you [ __ ] focus on the
podcast this listen man he is like
everybody's big brother those right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]